there's a pausing theme has devotees
honor and there's a reg X theme and our
aim in the end is to unite these all
into one at the top so that you're all
totally happy or completely unhappy as
the case may be we haven't done regular
expressions and the last one I did was
really very simple and straightforward
and show you absolutely nothing about
what can go wrong and some of you out
there coming up with the usual old jokes
quite right about oh you're implementing
using regular expressions now you've got
two problems yeah we'll look on in glee
as we now take the story a bit further
and say see what can go right and how
powerful regular expressions are but
also a little bit of what can go wrong
and why you've got to be careful in your
use so what can it be this marvelous new
example that consumes life the universe
and everything and exhibits a whole load
of new features and you're gonna be
quite convinced I'm off my head it's
roman numbers way way back when we first
here at Nottingham God Lex and yack in
UNIX version seven it was in the late
70s so believe me I have been or back in
those days I was setting rowing numbers
as an example of what legs remember the
regular expression based front-end to
your compiler does your identifies and
all that I thought all right as an
exercise just write a regular expression
that will accept Roman numbers all the
good ones and reject all the bad ones
now I can't emphasize too strongly that
rider is important it is very easy in a
regular expression quite easy to get it
to recognize what you want but will it
reject all the stuff that's bad and it
is sometimes so easy to overlook I say
we shame because when I said that
question I scratch down a quickened
easy answer which I now see is full of
holes because if you import into my
regular expression MMI I
again looking at Roman numbers mmm
aye-aye 2002 following but then I
thought but I thought now I didn't think
then what happens if I do am i I am 2002
shouldn't be there's a strict hierarchy
in the way these work so at this stage
we don't know how much if anything you
remember about Roman numerals so as an
extra bits we've put out a simple
tutorial on Roman numerals based around
this example but for those of you that
are totally happy with Roman numerals we
can just carry on with the main video
now so just to locate ourselves then and
do a few examples to make everybody
comfortable I'm into right now an M C D
X C I I start at the left we've got a
thousand then we see C D and remember
this is one of these subtraction things
C D is a hundred less than the 500 400
MCD so worked 1400 so far X C okay
that's 1990 III to 1492 what happens in
1492 Shawn in Western European folklore
Columbus discovered horizons you in
America I should have known that one
yeah right and of course the year we're
in at the moment as we film all of this
is that simple mmm xx
2021 that is dear to me I'm sure you'll
work out why yes it's got a lot of these
prepended abbreviation things in there
look MCN 1900 XL 10 less than 50 40 iv1
less if I'm not 244 let's focus
ourselves now on how would we do a
regular expression for all of this in
fact let's make things very very simple
and say all I'm gonna do at the moment
is
concentrate on getting a regular
expression pattern that will either
generate me one or two or three five
forgive me I'll carry on down here or
six seven eight oh nine and I won't go
any further than that
because tens is there is a new adventure
further to the left so those numbers
then from one to nine which I've written
know like that now I hope you can see
that if you're completely simple-minded
about this and don't want to do complex
regular expressions you really could
write yourself a great long alternation
as it's called in other words a great
big sequence of oars and you could do
everything from one up to thousands and
just have this walloping ray all claws
that your regular expression powers will
probably go bananas and say too many
alternations or something like this so
no that's not the way to do it what one
wants to do is to generalize and use as
it were elegant regular expression
capabilities to shorten this a bit so
there we are
the Roman numbers from one to nine all
written out
first of all let's try and separate
these things into classes and groups
that make sense there are two weird
things which involved the subtraction
rule you know like IV 1 less than 5 is 1
less than 10 I think we will do those
together because they're weird in the
same way if you like the other things
are much more regular like you go from 1
2 & 3 which is with III and similarly
here you get the same pattern but coming
after a V a V on its own or VI V double
IV triple I and so on so we've got three
groupings things involving eyes with or
without of the in front of them
and the two special cases IV and IX so I
would conjecture there's a wonderful
piece of regular expression covering so
far what we've done but something new
coming up so do pay attention
would be this my r-e is going to be I
now this is square choice brackets we
have seen these before
but whereas before I put Rangers inside
them you know I hate to say to said
anything nor to nine in one of those
digits
these aren't Rangers these are just
explicit possibilities inside square
brackets it's called a choice so I got
having a high if I'm on this side of the
expression but then it could be followed
by either an X or a V but it must be one
or other of them and only once
there's no repetition outside there's no
star there's no plus no nothing so those
are the special cases taking care of the
four and the nine now we put a walloping
great big or bar down the middle or if
it's not a special case it's a regular
straightforward case but we've been
clever with our arteries now oh yes look
at this now again I think this is
something we may have mentioned but
probably not another piece of regular
expression notation is if you put a
question mark after something it means
zero or one of so what I'm saying here
is I can either have a V or I don't need
a V how can you not need to be well
what's following on here is going to be
something that really is new this is a
counted repetition in curly braces zero
- look at that bound to win an award
let's just run through it the two
special cases are off on that left hand
side of the or bar but if you choose not
to go down that route you go to here and
it says oh well if it's not but one of
the two special cases then it's like the
following anything between 0 & 3 eyes I
mean you may not have eyes it's all you
can just have the on its own if you want
preceded by an optional V naught or one
these that's giving you the choice of
either 1 2 3 or 5 or 6 7 8 yeah yeah
that's right
but it's all to do with sometimes
having zero of something now hereby
hangs a tale about regular expressions
and those of you that keep on posting
these notices about you've got multiple
problems or expressions well here's
another one
it's the strange case of the empty
alternative which really can gang up to
get you because what you're saying here
in this expression is is it possible for
it to match nothing that's all and yet
that's a valid match yeah it is because
if you choose to ignore what's on the
left of the all bar here which can do
it's either/or we come here we say V who
can have zero or one of those so let's
have zero of them the I I can have
anything between or three of those so
let's choose zero them so in other words
choosing nothing at followed by nothing
is a valid match for a Roman number and
if you think about it is true nothing in
roman numbers is compulsory you can have
M's no M that you can have sees no
seizure you know all of them it's all
optional but as you start getting down
to the unit's digits you think I got out
of something
the paradox then about roman numbers
donors regular expression is you've got
all sorts of cases that yield you
nothing at all and yet you're going to
be very disappointed if you don't have
something but saying overall you must
have something that's not a context-free
assertion that's a context-sensitive
assertion so we live without for the
moment and I think also what I'd like to
just show you now if I can get the
screen fired up and I'm using orc here
to demonstrate this I'm going to add yet
another little piece of notation to all
of this I'm going to say that you can if
you want to insist that while you're
matching must just be a valid Roman
number on a line on its own with no
writing or messing about on either side
of it just the number start of the
number end of the number finish right
and you denote that by saying start of
string anchor end of string anchor
you're basically saying what
ever pattern there is must fit between
the start of the string called a line on
its own and the end of the string of the
new line right at the end now this is
the key thing about this those things if
you put them in are not options you
can't have zero over the main if you say
you must match the beginning of the line
you must most beginning on line if you
say you must match the end of the line
you cannot ignore it you can't have zero
of them so in a way this is a kind of
reality check and it's generally the
case that if you use these correctly you
won't end up with no strings being a
pseudo match because this thing is
saying well whatever the finite length
string is it's got to fit between
beginning of line end of line here's the
orc script that I hacked together to try
out a few alternatives and I decided to
go for this simple little piece first
can I do everything from 1 to 9 in a
single piece of regular expression and
you'll see here this is classic org you
give a regular expression pattern then
you give an action it's a C like syntax
even in org basically what I'm saying is
if I match that then I print out patent
b1 matched and so on now if you look
down here four of these things because
this is just a test bed for them a
commented out they will not be executed
the one that will be executed is the one
I've just been discussing with you here
which says I must match start of string
then here's my regular expression
pattern which I think will work from one
to nine inclusive and then it must match
end of string so I'm hoping that by
uncommenting this that this will work
and I'll type some good and bad Roman
numbers at it and for everyone is happy
with it will say pattern p0 matched is
and it will echo back what it your Roman
number that you put in so what I want to
do now is actually run that script that
we've been looking at all - take your
instructions from a file call just Roman
knot or okay so when that runs now it
should just hang there waiting from its
booty
a Roman number and remember it is going
to match that beginning of string piece
of regular expression and a string so
which one do you want me to try first
off let's go really simply and just go
for a number 5 V all on its home button
B 0 match this 5 all right like
here for cuz it's got that much yeah one
sort of idea would let's put one in that
it doesn't shouldn't go on that what you
want okay just put in C for computer
file whole C for computer file now in my
simple toss a valid Roman number yes but
it's not being covered by the bit of
regular expression I've done I've done a
piece of regular expression that
literally I hope there's one to nine and
nothing else let's see what happens
there it echoes it back but it doesn't
do anything with it
so let's now try 9 looking good
alright how about the ultimate test is
type in something utterly idiotic like
Hello no doesn't do anything with it
doesn't recognize it so we're back
showing the orca script again and let me
just remind you that what we've shown is
that as long as we put the anchors in at
the beginning and the end of this
pattern then our minimal testing but I
think we've tried all the options it's
recognized V it's recognized IX I lay
all this stuff that one is absolutely
fine and it rejects rubbish I've
actually put in as a comment stack
overflows assertion that this is the
thing that's the answer to life the
universe and everything let's move right
across the right and the first thing
you'll see here is the piece we've just
done for the units of it were I through
to IX but as you go left words can you
see that the beauty of this is that is
handled B units part of the roman
numbers it's dead easy to see therefore
that it's like a repetition of the same
idea but with different symbols when you
come to the tens range what are the
exceptions there XC tennis thunder and
exhale tennis and fifty it's just like
the eyes and the X's in V's were
look similar X or CL all it is an option
allow 450 followed by a tens digit zero
to three of them you can't say just one
two three because I'll on its own is
perfectly valid as a real man number so
you see that piece of pattern similar to
the far-right one but just with a
relabeling all most of the digits you're
using that copes of the tens up here is
coping with the hundreds of going on to
the thousands so the story finishes off
in here by saying ah you can have CM
hundred less than a thousand nine
hundred in other words CD for four
hundred and the midpoint of the range
which everything pivots around it was V
there it was L here it is going to be d
here I hope you will know that these
five hundred so there we are
how about you see three very similar
pieces of pattern for the hundreds the
tens and the units and right out here at
the far left Emma star and M star means
you can have zero or more 1000 so we've
got the basis there for something that
looks like it would do everything the
only problem is these empty matches but
that's such a big problem we probably
won't have an episode devoted to that
all on its own the man goes to town as
we would say to town the man goes
sounded to me twenty years ago and I
first stumbled on this very much like
Yoda the Jedi Master for those of you
coming into this cold and directs
because you saw the word Yoder and grep
over the entire universe